no jaywalking on my watch an undercover
officer accused of going too far during
a prostitution bust the Pittsburgh area
cop may have taken too much pleasure in
his work after he reportedly engaged in
an on-the-job sex act I think this is a
witch-hunt
I believe the officer did nothing wrong
he's the police union rep in the
Homestead Pennsylvania officer in
question says all this is being taken
out of context so let's check the
context written by the officer himself
detective Ronald the pelegrin according
to the criminal complaint the pelegrin
found this saucy online ad posted by one
Becky diamond he told his chief about it
the chief gave him the okay to perform a
sting the Pelican contacted diamond to
set up a meeting
he also swung by Walgreens to pick up
some supplies requested by the alleged
prostitute to pelegrin and his partner
drove to this house where de pelegrin
met up with diamond she got undressed he
got undressed and here's what the
pelegrin says happened next
Becky started to perform and when I said
okay the cops were coming you cool with
that mr. union rep in the course of
officers doing undercover work sometimes
they have to do what they have to do to
effectuate an arrest the pelegrin will
reportedly not be punished in fact when
a similar controversy erupted in the
area in 2010 the local district attorney
declared it's not inappropriate for a
police officers to get naked on the job
although actually having sex may
constitute outrageous government conduct
you filming it bump come on no cops have
better things to do
homestead suffers from some of the worst
crime rates in the Pittsburgh area it's
violent crime rate is about three times
the national average ditto for property
crimes so instead of searching for
prostitutes maybe homesteads finest
could spend more time searching for the
violent criminals on the most-wanted
list follow the show on Twitter submit
your nominees for next month and answer
this question what should we call cops
who waste time with stupid stuff when
they have better things to do that one
of them energy drinks uh uh not on my
watch